welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
Elizabeth Bradley the faculty director
for the Global Health Initiative and the
global health Leadership Institute both
of which are here at Yale she is also a
professor at yale school of public
health professor Bradley's research
focuses on health delivery systems and
quality improvement and has contributed
important findings about organizational
change and quality of care within the
hospital nursing home and hospice
settings she has been involved with
several projects that aim to strengthen
health systems in international settings
including China Ethiopia Liberia South
Africa and the United Kingdom today we
talk with Professor Bradley about the
global health efforts at Yale as well as
some of her recent work as a recipient
of a Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
grant welcome professor Bradley thank
you so much a great honor to be here
well thank you let's begin with talking
about the global health initiatives and
how they've evolved over the past three
years here at Yale sure thank you very
much it was in 2009 when President leben
and president-elect Sal of a recognized
that students at Yale were dying to do
more in the area of health promotion
globally and we really didn't have any
programs in that we had individual
courses we had individual faculty but
they decided we needed to coalesce the
resources that we had at Yale with in
something called the Global Health
Initiative within very and they asked me
to direct this initiative it is a
faculty-led initiative we have an
advisory group of faculty so that we try
very hard to make it interdisciplinary
from the very beginning the initiative
has ended up generating enormous
interest I think more than 30 or 35
courses have been now started in the
global health area we have an
undergraduate Global Health fellowship
and Global Health Studies program in the
graduate school we also have a global
health certificate now and finally in
the professional school
of nursing medicine and public health
they all have global health
concentrations now so it's a wholly
different than three years ago and what
does the future hold you think for the
Global Health Initiative and how are you
going to get there yeah I think the
future is very bright we have more and
more students taking these classes we
have more and more faculty who are
meeting each other this is another
enormous contribution of doing something
as a single University we can be more
unified in our approach for instance
before 2009 somebody in anthropology
might be working in Nepal and have no
idea that an economist is working there
also and if they could collaborate they
could really make change so because we
have more educational programs because
the faculty are meeting each other from
different disciplines I think it's very
very bright a couple of the things that
we absolutely need we know from our past
work is we have to have championship at
the top of the university and we have
that very strongly I think with Peter
Salome and we also have to have the
champions that are in the donor pools
that are really thinking how can a
university improve human health in the
globe and so far I think the donors that
we have it you'll have been very
generous but I think that's important to
continue to grow attract new faculty
attract some of the greatest minds in
this to Yale can you speak to any of
these successes that you've had to date
out in the world making specific impacts
and countries sure well I think my
favorite story is the one from Ghana and
this is because Ghana really had been a
country in which Yale was working with
very closely on a number of levels Linda
lorimer has visited you know it's a
country that we know the president of
etc and we ended up doing a huge
research project there Chris Udrih
really red LED this from the economics
department to understand what really is
the employment impact of mental health
problems in Ghana so this is a situation
where epidemiologist came together
anthropologists economists from Ghana
and from Yale and ultimately created the
research necessary to quantify what is
the GDP lost that is attributable to
mental health problems in the
country and ultimately the GDP
equivalent of the mental health problems
were like six or seven percent of the
gdp for gone to be able to itemize that
and then t that information up to the
key policy people including the
President of Ghana made all the
difference in the last eight months
they've written their first mental
health policy that is a state-of-the-art
policy for improving mental health and
Ghana now there's a lot of action to be
done on the ground which I think we have
the staff to help them with but it's a
place where research and practice met
and now I think many many people in
Ghana can be better off are you
targeting another country to do the same
kind of work we tried hard to find out
the countries that we're working with
what is their priority the reason this
worked in Ghana is going to asked for
help on this issue so they were primed
to do something and so when we work with
other countries we try to start with
that too so it's not the same issue in
another country but Ethiopia would be
another place we work like this with but
in that country where we work much more
on the quality of their hospitals and
then we're also working with several
other countries on different sort of
public health problems they've brought
to us we try to figure out who are the
faculty you can do something I'm right
great do you also send students out into
the world to try and assist absolutely
tell us talk a little bit about some of
the experiences yeah the students have
just been unbelievably creative in what
they have come up with and we do through
the Global Health Initiative we probably
send 50 or 60 students ultimately go
overseas to do something in the area of
Health and some of the more
transformational things that have
occurred we had one student last year
who went to Ethiopia specifically and
worked on a new method for giving it's
giving birth in health centers in
Ethiopia ninety-three percent of women
give birth in their village which would
be in a hut with no really sanitation or
anything like this and the student who
was pre-med actually got involved in
redesigning a prototype ideal kind of
Health Center where they would have the
right kind of gloves they would have the
right kind of sort of cultural norms to
be able to bring women to give birth
there and it's really in place now
really and that student was you know
they were part of a team but be
because they could be wrapped in a large
team of people working on something like
this it could make a difference the
student on their own probably couldn't
do that much but when you wrap them with
a ongoing initiative like this they can
be placed in a place to really be
successful another success story I think
is the Global Leadership Institute yep
so let's talk a little bit about that
tell us about it and how it is
successful how it fits into the program
overall yeah actually the global health
Leadership Institute is the flagship
program of the Global Health Initiative
it is what began the Global Health
Initiative and I think it's important
that it's a Leadership Institute this is
what distinguishes Yale in its global
health work if we look at the mission of
Yale in addition to discovering new
knowledge it is to educate people for
leadership so in the global health arena
the Leadership Institute works on
courses that are helpful for students
but also engaging with other countries
delegations who want to lead to make a
change so every year we have a
conference that's a five-day conference
where we invite for delegations from
four separate countries very high-level
policy makers and we embed students in
those delegations and faculty so then
you have a group who's really able to go
back they they develop a strategic plan
to address the problem they want and
they go back to their country and do
that so what are some of the countries
well Ghana Ethiopia Liberia has come
South Africa has come Brazil and Turkey
are going to come this year okay yeah
it's all different and I think I'm the
Brazil and Turkey effort is going to be
on how to this will bring together
several things we've done because it
will be focused on children and it will
be a focus on children's mental health
development at very young ages how do
you bring about healthy development to
hopefully build a healthy adult group so
I think it's going to be fast and I
wonderful lastly let's talk about your
the work you've been doing with the
melinda and bill gates foundation and
specifically the aided model sure now
this is fascinating work bill and
melinda gates foundation was worried
about a problem they had which is they
constantly are discovering new
transformational
innovations they could use but then
people wouldn't necessarily take them up
so whereas we look at Microsoft how
successful it was when Melinda and Bill
and Melinda Gates might go to Nepal and
say here's a new way in which will do
contraception can you use this widget
they realize no one was really taking it
up so they contracted with us to develop
a model of dissemination and diffusion
how do you take a good idea and put it
into practice we ended up getting a
multidisciplinary team together and
doing a very intensive literature review
of all kinds of public health
innovations that had spread virally and
studied exactly how did it occur and in
fact we ended up using a model from
molecular biology to understand well how
does HIV spread what how does it work
and can we look at socially can we look
at analogues to each of those steps and
see it in the social world we ended up
creating a model called Eden which has
five steps to it all that happened kind
of in a complex adaptive system but
assessing the environment innovating to
fit really a receptor user group
developing support around the innovation
political and economic support engaging
in the user community and then devolving
to other users through social networks
and the model is fascinating because
pretty much everybody that we work with
now as we are trying to spread our new
information we might get we think of
wrapping it in this model it's sort of a
way you know marketing people might know
this second nature but global health
people this isn't something that we've
really used now when you talk about that
model what comes to mind is the person
who was in Africa helping with the
deliveries and I immediately thought I
culturally would this be something that
the women would embrace going to a
hospital versus the the centuries-old
practice of giving birth in their hot so
was that an obstacle to overcome Norma's
obstacle and the way it was overcome is
one very important piece of giving birth
in Ethiopia is the coffee ceremony and
so we ended up including a full coffee
ceremony
in the clinic where you would give birth
so there you have to tell me what the
coffee ceremony yes oh you think opiate
coffee is the best of all but it is a
very carefully done ceremony where
people are served coffee three cups of
coffee that you have incense and popcorn
and it's really a busy while the woman
is giving birth or are after yeah but
it's a celebration and it's something
Ethiopians know to do and it costs money
and so what we ended up doing was
designing a method by which you could
make it culturally acceptable to go to a
clinic where the people who brought you
would be fed and you'd have you know a
feast and a coffee ceremony afterwards
so little things like that I mean there
are many many more clinical things but
that's something maybe the lay person
can understand you're sort of making
something fit in the culture right right
I think it got that that cultural aspect
and possibly also an economic a specter
are the two biggest hurdles toward why
something would not be taken and adapted
and used the magic sure politics okay an
economic right yeah and so we often find
that the economic world might be working
against the health world at times and we
have to work carefully to say how can we
use what is reality and maybe twist it a
little bit so that we can have our cake
and eat it too we can have a healthy
economy and we can have healthy people
right very good thank you so much for
being here today in sharing some of your
work well thank you for your interest is
very very fun great for more information
about professor bradley and her research
please visit our website at yale edu
slash mcmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you